How dare you.
I'm care of a very comfortable underarmor running shoes on.
How are those new shoes the other day?
Um,
they're a little too tight for me.
Okay.
They live,
they bind my feet a tad bit.
When I got to the store,
I had to swap them out for a,
I had a pair of converse all stars.
What'd you might go to?
You got easy,
right?
Jamie gave me a pair of Yeezys about a year ago and he just talked to him.
You just keeping them on ice.
Frozen dead socked dumb.
Is that what it's called?
That stock dead stock.
Dead stock.
Oh.
Do you know a dead naming is,
do you know what dead naming?
Is it a shoot?
No,
I know it's a new thing that's illegal on Twitter and this is something I wish I
knew I didn't know until after the podcast,
but dead naming is a,
it's banned.
So say if you decide tomorrow to become a woman and you're like,
I'm not no longer Bryan,
I'm Bryan Ina.
I'm like,
I'd be like Brianna if you thought this through or worse.
Okay.
So I'd be like,
uh,
okay,
Brianna,
but you're still a man and then boom,
that's deadnaming.
You can't call someone something other than their preferred gender.
So like if that identify as a woman,
but their biologically male,
you're not allowed to say their biologically male.
Oh,
you're not allowed to call them a man because that's deadnaming.
You're not allowed to call them.
Like you couldn't call Caitlyn Jenner.
Bruce if you called her Bruce,
you'd be dead naming her.
But that's just like,
that's not illegal or I mean like
Twitter rule.
If it is a new poll,
please pull it up.
Okay.
I did not know this.
It's been around for a while,
but I'm checking the Twitter.
That's kind of weird.
Dead Name.
He's been banned for a while or the term term has been around.
I just found out about the term maybe a couple weeks ago I'd heard the term for
the first time somebody wrote deadnaming and I was like,
what?
What is that?
And then I had to look it up.
Sorry Nicholas.
All the new rules we have to deal with fucking article.
There's an article that I was reading.
Go ahead.
I'm looking right at their terms of service.
It's directly word for word in there.
Okay.
Where does it say that?
Deadnaming of transgender individuals repeated or nonconsensual slurs or
epithets.
Racist and sexist tropes or other content that degrade someone.
Okay,
well hold on a second.
Like what does degrade someone?
So if you,
if you contact me and say,
hey bro,
you're fucking short.
You're not funny.
That's degrading.
Yeah.
Like is that not loud?
That's crazy.
You have to,
you have to have that be allowed.
We were hip targeting individuals with repeated slurs,
tropes or other content that it tends to dehumanize,
degrade,
or reinforce negative or harmful stereotypes about a protected category.
See,
that's where it comes from.
Like white people are not protected.
This includes targeted mis-gendering or dead naming of transgender,
transgender individuals.
I love how they just went with the,
this is a giant corporation and they just went with some new word that's only
been around for like a month.
How long has deadnaming been around for the urban dictionary?
I had it in there from 2014 oh really?
Never even heard that,
but they're on the ball.
Tell you that by Urban's there's this day ahead.
Twitter still allows goats sees and,
and all the porn.
You weren't as interesting to me.
Yeah.
Well porns consensual.
I love that.
Uh,
that's just hilarious.
I love that.
That's all.
I love the I t I did love the chaos of it all.
I love the fact that they're trying to solve it everything out.
I just think it's,
the whole thing is crazy.
It's so bizarre that
they're trying to,
in that sense with that like that's so vague.
Dehumanize or degrade.
Well,
every joke about someone,
every joke about Trump,
every single joke about Trump that every single comedian and or commentator in
or person makes is in some way degrading.
When you talk about how fucking stupid he was.
Like Rob Reiner had a joke about him,
called him a piece of shit or call them a piece of crap yesterday and said he
couldn't believe how fucking dumb he is.
Trump talking about Hillary though.
She,
he's doing it to heal 100% hundred percent.
Hundred percent.
So that's so vague.
That's so vague and dead naming is not a real word.
So like how are they using fake words in this shit?
They're trying to say it is now.
It is a real,
real word.
Yeah,
man.
I don't know if your name used to be Bruce and you change it to Kaitlin.
I can't say that.
That seems bananas.
Yeah,
that seems bananas.
So like if you're fucking with somebody,
say somebody became a woman and it's still an asshole.
You can't call him Mike,
you know?
Hey Mike,
look,
I sh,
I'm sure you're bitter about this whole changing your sex thing.
You can't bring that up.
But uh,
you're still an annoying guy.
You just don't every deck anymore by like,
if someone says that they can't say that,
why can't they say that they shouldn't?
That's to me stupid.
Wow.
Well,
I'm not saying that that's hurtful,
I guess to transgender people,
I guess.
And that's can can,
can be considered hate speech or hate whatever,
but own,
but
only when it comes to like gender,
right?
Like if you could,
you could tell someone,
hey,
you're short and fat and stupid and they don't.
No one cares.
True.
Right.
You could say you a,
you're ugly as fuck.
Your nose is disgusting.
Okay.
What happens there?
Is that the same,
what is it the same thing?
It might be if you do it repeatedly,
right?
If you just throw one out there,
probably,
okay.
Probably one time you could shit on someone's looks yet one.
But it's like,
like in deciding what you can and shit on someone for like what I'm saying is if
someone's an asshole and they're like,
here's a perfect one.
That woman who used to be a man,
she's a transgender woman who was in a store screaming at this kid behind the
counter that it's ma'am,
it's ma'am,
this is the perfect example of that.
The guy was terrified.
She's fucking huge and she used to be a guy and clearly still looks like a guy
and she's saying it's fucking ma'am,
like knock some shit over.
She got violent in the store.
Yeah.
In that situation.
You telling me that it's not cool to say,
how about you settle the fuck down because you look like a guy,
you're acting like a violent guy and you used to be a guy.
Pardon me if I think you're still a fucking guy that's dead naming,
but that's a good thing to say in that particular instance.
So without nuance,
right,
without context,
it's saying you can't say anything to degrade someone.
Well clearly that would degrade that guy,
but if that guy was saying,
fuck that kid,
he did it on purpose on Twitter,
you're saying someone can't respond,
hey man,
I'm sure you're really upset that you got your Dick removed and these still look
like a guy,
but fuck you.
Like why can't someone say that?
Because that's people communicating how they feel about you being a dick.
Like if you start out being a dick and then they communicate about you being a
dick by being a dick as well,
are we banning this?
It's their pride is covering their butts.
There's pride night.
You know what?
Like kind of like Jamie said,
it's dangerous in a lot of ways.
It's dangerous to control people's thoughts and behavior because who are you to
say and when does it end?
You know?
It just keeps going and going and going and going.
It gets,
it gets very slippery when you have one group that thinks it's right and they're
trying to control another group that thinks they're right.
Man,
that is a,
it's,
it seems so simple when you're just talking about dead naming transgender people
or not degrading people based on their looks or their ethnicity or their this or
that.
But what you're doing is you're trying to dictate how humans communicate with
each other and people don't like it when you tell him what to do.